the
9373rd meeting of the Security Council
is called to order
the provisional agenda for this meeting
is
threats to International Peace and
security
the agenda is adopted
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
I invite the following briefers to
participate in this meeting
Mr Bryce green
independent journalist
and Mr Jeffrey a Brodsky
it is so decided
yeah the security Council will now begin
its consideration of item two of the
agenda
I now give the floor to the first
briefer requested by the Russian
Federation Mr Bryce Queen
thank you
good afternoon my name is Bryce green I
am an organizer a graduate student a
freelance media critic my work has been
published by fairness and accuracy in
reporting and has been republished in
other outlets including salon and the
monthly review online I am also a United
States citizen and thus I bear the
responsibility for the actions of my own
government to the extent that I have the
ability to influence them but I appear
here before the security Council on my
own behalf and represent no government
or organization
it is Media criticism work and studying
the Ukraine war in general that brought
me to investigate the Nordstrom attack
and the international response to it
for a brief background beginning around
midnight on September 26 of last year
2022 a series of leaks were detected
along the route of the Nordstrom
pipelines seismology reports indicated
clearly that this was the result of
deliberate sabotage and not an accident
for Western officials experts in the
press the culprit was clear Russia
numerous articles government officials
immediately pointed the finger at Russia
and what was their explanation as to why
Russia would blow up its own pipeline
well even the New York Times
acknowledged that quote it is unclear
why Moscow would seek to damage
installations that cause gas prom
billions of dollars to build and
maintain
but the Press quickly fell into line
with the motive that the attacks were
just quote a reminder from Moscow
according to Western officials experts
in media Russia attacked themselves to
intimidate the West
now there are all sorts of problems with
blaming Russia for one gas flows from
Russia were a major point of Leverage
over Europe with respect to their
support for Ukraine removing that
leverage would and has severely harmed
Russian strategic interests on that
front
also Russia has already made statements
urging Germany then suffering from high
energy prices to end the sanctions
against Nordstrom pipeline saying that
both lines could be opened importantly
we know now that the leading
investigator from Sweden has told the
Press quote do I think it was Russia
that blew up Nordstrom I never thought
so it's not logical
the other problem with immediately
blaming Russia was that another
immediately apparent culprit the United
States was almost completely ignored as
a potential suspect why is that as we
shall see the circumstantial case for
U.S complicity in the text is far
stronger than the case for Russia
it has long been a U.S and NATO strategy
to prevent the integration between
Western Europe and Russia this was clear
in the early post-war days NATO's first
Secretary General Lord Hastings this may
made it clear that NATO's role as an
organization was to and I quote to keep
the Russians out the Americans in and
the Germans down and that hasn't really
changed over the last 80 years
since the announcement of the second
Nordstrom project three successive U.S
administrations have done their utmost
to stop the pipeline the Obama Trump and
Biden administrations all opposed it
even people who plan out the global
strategy for the military have taken
these things into account we see this in
a study from the Rand Corporation in
2019 this study was looking at ways to
over extend and unbalance Russia
specifically it looked at how best to
exploit quote Russia's economic
political and Military vulnerabilities
and anxieties
this Ranch study prophetically
recommended that the U.S start Pro
providing more U.S military equipment
and advice to Ukraine in order to quote
lead Russia to increase its direct
involvement in the conflict and the
price it pays for it end quote at the
same time it acknowledged that quote
Russia might respond by mounting a new
offensive and seizing more Ukrainian
territory
we now know how that went so clearly
this is an important piece of literature
with respect to understanding what's
going on over there
more relevant to the day's discussion
the study included a recommendation to
reduce Russian natural gas exports and
hinder pipeline expansions the study
noted that quote a a first step would
involve stopping Nordstrom 2 in quote
and that natural gas from the United
States and Australia could provide a
substitute
I should note that the study now if you
look at it online has a warning that
it's being misused by pro-russian
propagandists however I believe the
words of the study speaks for themselves
as do the actions and words of U.S
officials
recall at the start of the Biden
Administration the U.S Secretary of
State Anthony blinken told Congress that
he was determined to do whatever he
could to prevent nordstream 2 from being
completed under Secretary of State
Victoria Newlin told the Press if Russia
invades one way or another Nordstrom 2
will not go forward in February
President Biden told reporters if Russia
invades there will be no longer a
Nordstrom too we will bring an into it I
promise you we will be able to do that
and after the attack you know will
blinken and Newland celebrated the
destruction of the pipelines calling it
a tremendous opportunity
now on February 8th of this year veteran
American journalist Seymour Hirsch
published a major article hosted on his
sub stack about who was responsible
responsible for the attacks the story
was based on Anonymous sources with
knowledge of the operation one of whom
was willing to go on the record
the story allege that the pipeline was
attacked on orders from Joe Biden and
his National Security Council
originating with plans that predated the
war The Story Goes that U.S Navy divers
used the ball tops exercises in June
2022 as covered to lay explosives on the
pipeline and these explosives were later
detonated three months later in
September
now analysts within the open source
intelligence Community have pushback
citing the differences in some of the
vessels involved in Hirsch's story and
what's available on open source but
Hirsch has responded to these criticism
by pointing out that covert operations
would likely not leave a trail that's
searchable by the public
the White House for their part has
called Hershey's story completely and
utterly false but given the interests of
the U.S in these pipeline explosions
these denials carry no information
there has been information collected by
researchers including the Swedish
scholar Ola tunander who which appeared
to corroborate elements of hersch's
story however to my knowledge
these leads have yet to be seriously
investigated by Western investigators
now a month after Hirsch's article was
published a new story emerged in both
the the Western and in both the U.S and
European press
alleging that a quote pro-ukrainian
group was behind the attack these
reports citing information ostensibly
gathered in the ongoing German
investigation alleges that a small boat
the Andromeda was a key part of The Plot
to Bomb the pipelines however some
investigators are still skeptical of the
role it may have played
however much like the US Ukraine has
ample reason to want the pipeline gone
in 2021 Ukrainian and Polished ministers
published an article in political titled
nordstream 2 has damaged the West enough
time to put an end to it
corroboration for the story came from
the Washington Post who published in
addition to the ongoing Discord leaks
story according to U.S intelligence
intercepts of high-level Ukrainian
Communications zielinski had been
advocating making Bolder moves against
Russia including attacks on pipelines we
also learned that the U.S was training
ukrainians and undersea operations
similar to the ones that must have been
carried out against the Nordstrom too
according to numerous media reports in
the western press Dutch intelligence
agencies passed on information about a
potential Ukrainian attack to the
American Central Intelligence Agency who
then warned Germany about a potential
attack thus according to mainstream
sources in the west the U.S had some
degree of advanced knowledge of the
attacks one thorough investigation comes
from journalist James Bamford who
reported that the U.S is almost certain
to know more about the attack than
they're letting on whether they or the
ukrainians committed the attack and it's
worth quoting some excerpts from his
report
he says quote U.S intelligence
constantly monitors Russia and other
countries in near real time from beneath
the Seas including from under the Baltic
where a rays of acoustic sensors
Tethered to the sea floor would
certainly have been able to pinpoint the
exact time and location of these massive
undersea explosions
later on he says even more important by
analyzing the distinct engine sounds of
the ships submarines and uuvs passing
above in the days surrounding the
sabotage U.S intelligence would have
likely been able to quote fingerprint
them and determine their nationality and
exact identity while the transponder on
a ship can be switched off when you get
invisible to satellites as long as its
engines are running it can be detected
by the U.S Navy's little-known and
highly secret worldwide integrated
undersea surveillance system
therefore it is likely that the U.S
knows far more about what happened than
they are letting on
to recap the consensus among Western uh
Western press and Western uh officials
is that the United States or Ukraine was
involved in the attack and if Ukraine
was involved the attack then it surely
had U.S acquiescence now everyone here
likely knows all of this but given the
U.S power to veto any motion by the
security Council it's likely not going
to change anytime soon so what will
change that and now I direct my comments
to members of the western press you know
people at CNN The Washington Post the
New York Times major American journals
with the resources and the power to
investigate the attack and demand
responses from American officials
but there have been very few reports
actually analyzing the situation and
seriously weighing the evidence and very
few questions have been asked of the
Biden Administration
an article from The New York Times is
emblematic of the general attitude of
the country they wrote quote a flurry of
new findings and competing narratives
has sown distrust among Western allies
now most critically the times
acknowledges that quote it may be in no
one's interest to reveal more no one's
interests is this serious they've
abdicated their role to hold power
accountable
in conclusion the West has let these
Revelations sink into the background
despite the Parlor game about whether or
not it was American or Ukrainian divers
who actually planted the charges
analysts and officials across the West
seem to agree on key facts that the
attacks originated from the West
the ball talks exercises were the
staging ground for these attacks and the
U.S knows a lot more than it is
currently sharing
these facts and their implications need
to be seriously understood and addressed
by both the security Council and the
world's press Western media is not
seriously pressing for answers right now
and this distinction between the U.S did
it and Ukraine did it versions of the
story are a distraction it is a
distinction without a difference both
stories clearly indicate Western
complicity and a conspiracy of Silence
at the absolute least I urge the U.N
security Council and especially Western
press to utilize their considerable
power and authority to shed some light
on the situation and to hold accountable
these individuals and organizations and
Nations that may be responsible for this
act of Terror
thank you
I thank Mr Green for his briefing
and I'll give the floor to the second
briefer requested by the Russian
Federation Mr Jeffrey vodky
thank you very much
my name is Jeffrey Brodsky
I'm the only journalist to travel to all
four blast sites of the north stream one
and two pipelines on the Baltic Sea
I've been investigating the nurturing
sabotage since the day it occurred on
September 26 2022.
I appear before the United Nations
security Council on my own behalf I
represent no government or organization
in the testimony that I will deliver
the attack of the north stream pipelines
is likely the most severe Act of
eco-terrorism and the largest instance
of industrial sabotage in history
on the United Nations Charter two of the
functions and powers of the security
councilor are quote to maintain
International Peace and Security in
accordance with the principles and
purposes of the United Nations and to
investigate any dispute or situation
which might lead to International
friction end quote
bringing the perpetrator of the north
stream sabotage to International Justice
and compensating the harm parties will
advance International Peace and security
and reduce International friction
as well as further aim further the aim
of preventing future attacks on critical
International infrastructure
I therefore appeal to this to the
security Council to execute its function
and power under the U.N Charter by
conducting an impartial investigation
into the north stream sabotage
in late may I participated in
independent investigation to all four
blast sites of the Nordstrom one and two
Pipelines
through the investigation underwater
drone images and videos and sonar images
of the damaged pipelines were obtained
these images and videos had never been
seen by the public before and they offer
unique insights into the amount of
explosives used in the attack
the charges the type of charges and
their placement
by analyzing the expedition's data both
military and civilian experts have drawn
conclusions about how the pipelines were
damaged
notably previous reports stating that
over 500 kilograms of explosives were
used at each blast site were proven
inaccurate
based on my reporting and the
expedition's findings the actual amount
of explosives used
range from 10 to 50 kilograms
likely leaning towards the lower end of
this range
however
neither the data obtained on the
Expedition nor my investigative work has
yet been able to conclusively attribute
the sabotage to specific nation state
perhaps the only Perhaps Perhaps only
the United Nations security Council
would be able to conclusively attribute
the sabotage to a specific nation state
and to reach this objective I am
confident that many people around the
world would welcome this body's
assistance
the European Union moreover warned that
quote
any deliberate disruption of European
energy infrastructure is utterly
unacceptable and will be met with a
robust and United response end quote
yet it remains unclear what actions the
EU has taken to identify the perpetrator
of the attack
furthermore it is widely known among
members of this body and the general
public that three countries Germany
Denmark and Sweden have carried out
investigations into the sabotage
regrettably none of these countries has
yet disclosed the results of its
investigations
despite nine months having passed since
this habitage took place
I personally contacted the German Danish
and Swedish investigators several times
for their comment on my reporting and on
the expedition's findings but they have
refused to offer any comment
it is unclear why these countries have
not shared their findings with the
public
the Baltic Sea is likely the most
trafficked and monitored body most with
the most heavily trafficked and
monitored body of water in the world
as one European parliamentarian told me
quote
do you think that a terrorist attack
like this in international waters in a
sea that is observed by many different
surveillance systems that this could
happen without anybody taking notice
that's hard to believe it wasn't an
attack on Mars it was in the Baltic Sea
end quote
there is sufficient economic motivation
for the three countries to release their
findings as well
the pipelines cost over 23 billion
dollars to build and their owners
operators and stakeholders stakeholders
are from a number of countries
a good deal of the inflation that is
currently hurting families and small
businesses throughout Europe has been
brought on by the lack of inexpensive
Natural Gas
and Germany's industrial base has
suffered particularly from the sabotage
as manufacturing costs have risen
nordstream one alone could Supply 58
percent of Germany's annual gas
consumption
while according to a study quote
Germany's three-decade long Surplus
flipped into a deficit driven by the
rise in gas prices end quote
furthermore the ecological impact of the
sabotage is likely tremendous
the explosions caused what could be the
largest release of methane in history a
greenhouse gas more than 25 times as
potent as carbon dioxide at trapping
heat according to the United Nations
protection Environmental Protection
Agency
unfortunately as of now Germany Denmark
and Sweden have shown no willingness to
share the results of their
investigations with the public
a particular interest
Sweden was the first country to arrive
at the crime scenes and conducted
investigations including the removal of
debris and materials
in fact Sweden investigators removed
debris and materials for one of the
crime scenes on at least two occasions
in October of 2022 when expression a
Swedish newspaper published images and
videos of the ruptures in one of the
pipelines media attention on the
sabotage increased again
the Swedish investigators subsequently
closed off the area for some days and
did some more investigative work
it remains unclear why Swedish
investigators took these actions and
what information the debris and
materials that they removed could
provide about the sabotage
and even when or if these three
countries released their findings it
doesn't appear as if Sweden in
particular will tell the world who is
responsible for the sabotage
the Swedish prosecutor quote has
previously said that the main purpose of
the Swedish preliminary investigation is
to find out whether Sweden or Swedish
infrastructure has been used for the
attack and whether there are people who
should be prosecuted for participation
end quote
that was an excerpt from an English
translation of an article published in a
European newspaper last May
the north stream sabotage stands as one
of the most significant acts of
ecoterrorism and Industrial sabotage in
history
it also represents one of the most
pressing geopolitical mysteries of our
time
is it sufficient to inform global
missions the number of numerous
businesses and the many countries
affected by the sabotage merely about
whether Sweden or Swedish infrastructure
has been used in the attack and whether
there are people who should be
prosecuted for participation
I think not
the nation-state or nation states
responsible for this sabotage must be
held accountable for their violation of
international law the perpetrators must
be identified brought to Justice and the
affected parties must be duly
compensated
many people worldwide have lost faith in
National and international institutions
I hope that condemning I I hope that
condemning this act of global terrorism
and swiftly establishing a U.N security
council-led investigation into the in
this enormous Global crime can help
restore some of this lost faith
the world is watching and expecting the
U.N security Council to uncover the
truth about the sabotage and share this
truth publicly
thank you very much
I thank Mr Brodsky for his briefing
I now give the floor to those council
members who wish to make statements
I give the floor to the representative
of the Russian Federation
pipelines in the Baltic Sea in September
2022. they confirm our version of the
events namely that carrying out this
crime without the direct participation
or at the very least the cover of a
state entity would have been simply
impossible
topic which has been the focus of the
security council's attention for several
months now at our behest that no matter
what format it is discussed in in the
security Council and whatever the
positions of delegations may be on the
draft resolution we proposed nearly all
the members of the council have
consistently condemned this crime and
noted the importance of establishing the
truth and identifying those responsible
at the same time Western College tried
to convince the council that there was
no added value in international efforts
until until the completion of national
investigations carried out by Berlin
Copenhagen and Stockholm they
persistently urged to wait until those
investigations were completed well it
has now been almost 10 months since the
sabotage and four months since the vote
on our draft resolution
there has been no information provided
to the security Council and the
International Community until yesterday
German Danish and Swedish authorities
southernly stubbornly refused to provide
any antenna intelligible response during
numerous requests and appeals they did
not provide one to the message sent in
October 22 by the prime minister of the
Russian Federation on the need to
conduct a comprehensive investigation of
the incident with the participation of
Representatives of Russia
authorities and the gas prom company
to the numerous notes sent by Russian
missions
we have repeatedly drawn his attention
to the fact that their entire response
amounted to routine formal non-answers
with a refusal to cooperate under
extremely ludicrous and foreign
confusion and dissatisfaction due to the
absence of any information on the
national investigations as a result
after receiving yet another yellow card
from the majority of council members
Berlin Copenhagen and Stockholm decided
to prepare the collective letter that
was
unfortunately it is also very
reminiscent of a non-answer and cannot
replace a full pledge briefing by them
to the members
where we could ask them questions of
which a great deal
assertion that Russia was allegedly
informed about the progress of the
investigation the choice of warding also
indicates that the authorities of
Germany in Denmark and Sweden are
deliberately trying to prepare the
members of the council not to expect any
concrete results from these
investigations
and in any case it is impossible to say
when they will be completed even more
telling is the language from the parts
devoted to the Swedish investigation I
quote the ongoing investigation will
show whether anyone can be suspected of
and later prosecuted for this crime
Ukrainian
avatars were behind the attack yet they
allegedly had nothing to do with the key
of regime at the same time it is telling
meanwhile that in a recent interview
with the times the head of Ukrainian
intelligence Donovan responds to a
direct question about the involvement of
Ukrainian authorities in the pipeline
incident and other terrorist attacks
said literally we are doing this right
now we use direct actions we use them
and we love them we're proud of using
them and we're not afraid of using them
anywhere in this world against you
let's be honest the bravado of the Ring
leaders in Kiev does not Inspire
confidence they are prepared to take
credit for any accomplishments just to
shift Focus from their failures on the
front and flagrant violations of human
rights in the country taking place in
the context
dictatorship we also recall the
publication of a highly plausible
version of events by the American
investigative journalists
referencing reliable sources he later
cited information without following the
March meeting between U.S President Joe
Biden and German councilor Olaf Schultz
American and German intelligence was
instructed to prepare and promote an
alternative version for the media about
who blew up the North Street
immediately after this
began to bring up in the western media
claiming that the discretion of the
Nordstrom could have been perpetrated by
a small group of near amateurs who had
neither
serious resources
State backing and this is despite the
fact that numerous independent experts
including those who spoke before
yesterday
in any case it is not something that the
coastal States in this region at the
very least which is considered one of
the most closely monitored
and how do you square this with repeated
threats against the north stream from
U.S top leadership
these have sounded more than once
however as soon as inconvenient facts
came to light Americans in their
European allies began to interfere with
an international investigation in every
way possible moreover unlike many other
U.N member states they were not
interested in efforts under the offices
they stand to gain much more in a
situation where Western States enjoy
carte blanche an absolute impunity
within the framework of a rules-based
order imposed on the whole world and
which has nothing to do with
international law
sabotage
we expect the authorities of Germany
Denmark and Sweden to take concrete
steps to conduct an objective and
transparent investigation to all the
circumstances of the incident with the
obligatory participation of Russian
investigative authorities and other
interests parties in the meantime we
reserve the right to conduct our own
investors
statement in the letter from the
authorities of Germany Denmark and
Sweden that access to the crimes
we presume that in this case our
investigative authorities can
independently examine the crime scene at
any time as part of the criminal
proceedings initiated by the prosecutor
General's Office of the Russian
Federation pursuant to the article on
active International terrorism
Russian Federation continue raising the
issue of the Nordstrom sabotage and the
council until the perpetrators are
identified and held accountable the
letter mentioned today leaves that this
is not a goal that the three National
investigations need to accomplish we
will use all the means that are disposal
to make sure that this goal is in fact
achieved we trust that our
constructively minded colleagues in the
security Council and other members of
the International Community will support
our efforts we're open to cooperation
thank you
I think the representative of the
Russian Federation for their statements
and I give the floor to representative
of Ecuador
president Mr President
to the briefers
[Music]
I also read its
annexes
regarding their National influence
these investigations are complex
and that they involve technical
scientific and logistical aspects among
others it is
civilian infrastructure including energy
infrastructure
in addition to jeopardizing safe
Maritime and navigation
endangering local marine life
has positive possibly devastating
and these consequences were Unleashed
when the explosions
hundreds of millions of cubic meters
into the atmosphere we must avoid a
situation where by acts such as this in
the midst of a highly complex geological
situation exceptions left to right or
triggers actions with unpredictable
consequences
[Music]
utmost caution and restraint
we will continue to be guided
foreign
[Music]
I think the representative electoral for
their statement and I give the floor to
the representative of France
Mr President
it is the third time more than less than
a month
has called for a discussion on this
matter
however no new development has occurred
which would justify yeah
and noting that there is a contradiction
between
concerns following the attack it was
perpetrated against critical European
and Its Behavior
we have no
[Music]
I thank the representative of France for
their statement I give the floor to the
representative of Ghana
Mr President I thank the briefest for
their respective views on this agenda
item we also take notes of the joint
letter submitted by Denmark Germany and
Sweden on developments related to their
respective ongoing National
investigations on the sabotage of a
non-stream pipeline Ghana continues to
be deeply concerned about the sabotage
against the north stream one in two gas
pipelines last September giving the
impacts on the marine environment and
also the potential economic humanitarian
and security risk that arise from the
destruction of such critical
infrastructure of a trans-boundary
nature we therefore maintain our support
for the ongoing National investigations
by the countries of Interest
particularly Denmark and Sweden in whose
exclusive economic zones the incident
occurred as well as Germany
in view of the sustained interests of
the International Community on the
matter we encourage frequent updates and
readily available information on the
status of Investigations to bring
Clarity on the facts and help to
determine the necessity or otherwise of
an international investigative process
pending the conclusion of the national
investigations we add cooperation among
all relevant stakeholders including the
operators of the pipeline with objective
of arriving at a single narrative on the
circumstances resulting in the
unfortunate incidents
I wish to end by retreating our previous
appeals to all consent to exercise
restraints against unilateral actions
that may be detrimental to peace I thank
you Mr President
I think the representative of Garner for
their statement and they give the floor
the representative of Brazil
thank you Mr President Mr President your
colleagues I thank the briefers for
their views and assessments I also take
note of the latter circulated Yesterday
by Denmark Germany and Sweden
immediately after the north stream one
and two gas pipeline explosions last
September
Brazil as well as other council members
expressed deep concern about what was
clearly a threat to International Peace
and security
we consider it essential to identify
those responsible and hold them
accountable for their actions
for this reason last March we supported
a proposal for the launching of an
international investigation coordinated
by United Nations in support of efforts
by national authorities
we are aware that Denmark Germany and
Sweden are conducting investigations on
the incident We Trust in their
objectivity and await the disclosure of
information that may shed light on this
act of sabotage which resulted in
immense economic losses environmental
damage
Brazil underscores the importance that
the conclusions of the investigations in
progress are disclosed as soon as
possible
the consequences of the incident cause
concern to the International Community
especially in view of the proliferation
by the media of narratives and
unconfirmed versions of the events
we understand the need for secrecy and
time for the proper conduct of the
procedures however the lack of responses
almost 10 months after the explosions
has produced anxieties and deepened
tensions even among members of this
Council
we encourage increased cooperation
between states directly affected and
additional efforts to prevent
misinformation and ensure that the
results of Investigations are known soon
with dual transparency thank you Mr
President
I thank the representative of Brazil for
that statement and I give the flow to
the representative of Mozambique
Mr President
Mozambique wishes to thank the briefers
a surprise green and Mr Jeffrey Brodsky
for they are important and insightful
updates
almost a year
has gone by
since this grave incident
occurred in the Baltic Sea in September
despite the prevailing understanding
that this was indeed an act of sabotage
and that a serious violation
of international law had occurred
we are still
searching for answers
that can be conducive to the
determination
of the truth
by principle and policy
Mozambique does not condone
with a deliberate destruction and
weaponization of critical and
transnational infrastructures such as
the node stream pipeline
we hold this View
within the spirit that led to the
adoption of Security Council resolution
2341 or 2017.
that aims to protecting critical
infrastructures of such attacks
we are aware of the ongoing
investigations into the incident by
competent authorities in three National
jurisdictions of Germany Sweden and
Denmark
we also take note of their commitment to
a fair and impartial process to
establish the truth
surrounding what appears to be a
deliberate Act of sabotage
as the primary organ
responsible for International Peace and
security it is a legitimate that the
security Council should be kept abreast
of the results of the tri-national
investigations
preliminary or otherwise
an infrastructure of transnational reach
and international ownership structure
the search for an answer is fair and
warranted
as a country that is investing
heavily in a regulated and orderly
energy infrastructure for its
development and the development of the
region as a whole Mozambique
supports the Speedy conclusion of
objective impartial and professional
investigations into the incident
I thank you Mr President
I thank the representative of Mozambique
for their statement
I now give the floor to the
representative of Switzerland
the consequences
I thank you
I think the representative of
Switzerland for their statement
and I give the floor to the
representative of Gabon
I thank you Mr President
foreign
[Music]
diplomatic solution to this crisis I
thank you thank you
I thank the web censor of Gabon for
their statement and I give the floor to
the representative of Malta
thank you president
Malta reiterates strong condemnation of
the act of sabotage targeting the
Nordstrom 1 and 2 pipelines that the
court occurred last September
such actions pose a serious threat to
energy security and Regional stability
likewise we reiterate our Firm Stance
against any form of disruption to
critical energy infrastructure
furthermore the subsequent leaks pose a
significant risk to the country's
concerned and jeopardized an important
pathway for transporting a vital energy
resource
they also added additional pressure on
developing countries and Global energy
markets which were already negatively
impacted by Russia's aggression against
Ukraine
this incident serves as a reminder of
the vulnerability of essential energy
infrastructure
president
as we have stated before we support and
Trust the ongoing investigations by
Denmark Germany and Sweden we have no
doubt that these investigations will
disclose and establish the truth behind
this deliberate Act
it is crucial to ensure the completion
of these National processes without any
external interference
we have full confidence in their
impartiality and credibility
as we all know investigations of this
magnitude take time
persistent claims that 9-1 should have
been enough to investigate and establish
the truth on this matter or unfounded
such insinuations do not move us any
closer to the throat and only serve to
generate unfounded suspicions and
distrust among states
to conclude we reiterate our convinced
position that introducing further
investigations at this juncture will
seriously risk impeding progress and
potentially have counterproductive
effects on the ongoing process I thank
you president
I thank the representative of Malta for
their statements and I give the floor to
the representative of the United Arab
Emirates
Mr President
the United Arab Emirates reaffirms its
unqualified condemnation of last
September's acts of sabotage which
targeted the north Scream 1 and 2
pipelines in the Baltic Sea
such attacks threaten International
Security stability and prosperity they
are dangerously disruptive to Global
energy markets which depend upon
International cooperation and cost
significant ecological damage they Merit
this council's sober attention and the
international community's concern
furthermore we underscore our respect
and support for the ongoing National
investigations by the competent
authorities in all relevant countries
and we continue to monitor their
progress
we also note the heightened
International in interest in this issue
and recognize the legitimate equities at
stake and therefore encourage
cooperation between all relevant
countries and entities
in that vein we welcome the updates on
the status of the investigations offered
to this Council by Denmark Germany and
Sweden through their joint letters of 21
February and 10 July 2023 which were
sent to the president of the security
Council
we appreciate the increased information
sharing reflected in yesterday's letter
as investigations are still ongoing it
is vital to avoid pre-judging their
outcomes we await their Swift conclusion
the transparent communication of their
findings And Timely updates as
appropriate
to conclude the UAE takes a tax against
cross-border critical infrastructure
extremely seriously they must never be
tolerated and we expect to see those
responsible held to account thank you Mr
President
I thank the representative of the UAE
for their statement and they give the
floor to the representative of Albania
thank you Mr President
would have been a reference to our last
statement on this issue a week or so ago
since there is nothing new on the matter
being here I would like to make the
following points
first we have said it many times and we
reiterate it again we have been and are
deeply concerned by an apparent Act of
sabotage on the pipelines North stream
one and two in the exclusive economic
zones of Denmark and Sweden in the
Baltic Sea such acts are unacceptable
we our full support for the
investigations initiated by the national
authorities of Denmark Germany and
Sweden to determine the origin and the
damage and the possible perpetrators
we welcome their joint letter of
yesterday indicating that the
investigation is underway and we have
full confidence in their objectiveness
and comprehension company has
comprehensiveness
the three countries that are carrying
the investigation have strong
traditional institutions and
unquestionable Records on the rule of
law
second
this is the third meeting on the issue
seamlessly called by Russia within less
than one month
it is obvious that such investigations
processes are complex and need time as
the latter highlights in the meantime
internet is full of all kinds of
information this and misinformation
including colorful theories Advanced by
dependent and independent journalists
especially by those who have the luxury
to use their freedom as they wish
we all want to see the findings but we
must be patient and wait for the ongoing
investigations conclusions
therefore bringing this discussion
incessantly in the agenda of the
security Council equals more to a
political pressure and whenever to
divert attention from other issues
the politicization of the investigation
process and the artificial pressure on
it by the heated rhetoric do not help to
expedite the process as we all want
third while we all want to know the
truth on the acts of the sabotage the
obsession in singling out this one issue
is both cynical and preposters at a time
when for more than 500 Days Russia has
been waging unjustified aggressive and
merciless war on its neighborhood
devastating human economic consequences
today like every year on 11th of July we
commemorate the severnita genocide
the scale and depravity of this strategy
continues to burden our souls 28 years
later
I mention it not only because it
deserves commemoration with humbleness
but also because it happened during the
last war in Europe and we have committed
to never let those tragic events repeat
and this is why I insist that when it
comes to the question of war in Ukraine
there are far more important than
consequential questions that need and
should have our attention on a daily
basis such as the killing of more than 9
000 enough innocent civilians including
500 children the whole range of the
Despicable crimes committed by the
Russian army the deliberate destruction
of residential areas by way so of
illegally acquired Iranian Kamikaze
drones the thousands of Ukrainian
children forcefully deported in Russia
and given for adoption the frightening
magnitude and cost of deliberate
destruction of Civilian infrastructure
and the decimation of economy are in
Ukraine
a joint assessment of the United Nations
World Bank group European commission and
the government of Ukraine estimates that
the cost of reconstruction and Recovery
in Ukraine has grown to
411 billion US dollars
the report finds that direct damages to
buildings and infrastructure amounts to
more than 135 billion US dollars and the
most affected areas are housing
transport energy commerce and Industrial
and agriculture otherwise the backbone
of the economy and that was last month
the cost of War including for Russia
itself increases every hour every day
therefore and this will be my final
Point instead of calling for meetings on
the no stream Pipeline and wasting
council's time in futile politicization
of an ongoing investigation process
Russia could be more useful and
productive if it would put an end to the
war in Ukraine and seriously engage in
diplomacy by starting with the complete
withdrawal of its troops from the
territory of Ukraine and I thank you
I thank the representative of Albania
for their statement and I give the
floors the representative of China
foreign
investigations
even if it is only a milestone
positive steps accordingly
thank you president
I think the representative of China for
their statement and I give the floor so
representative of the United States
thank you Mr President as others have
noted this is the third time in less
than a month that Russia has called for
the council to discuss Nordstrom
Russia's efforts to try to use this
Council as a platform for its
disinformation
are as cynical as they are transparent
bludgeoning the council with repetitive
meetings will not change the facts on
the ground
as we have emphasized many times we do
not condone this attack on critical
infrastructure
we remain confident in the ongoing
competent and credible
investigations underway by Germany
Sweden and Denmark
we thank these countries for their
commitment to diligence and impartial
investigations into the attack
and for their recent letter on this
topic to the council
Russia's unabating unsubstantiated
so-called concerns about the
transparency and impartiality of these
investigations ring as Hollow as its
assertions that it had no relationship
with the Wagner group and had no plans
to invade Ukraine
the country's directly involved should
be permitted to conclude their
investigations without undue pressure
and specious allegations
Russia cannot and should not be allowed
to prejudge or Prejudice the results of
these investigations prior to their
conclusion
the hypocrisy is on Full display
Russia claims to respect sovereignty and
territorial Integrity while invading its
Sovereign neighbor and attempting to
Annex its territory
Russia now disregards the jurisdiction
of competent National authorities
carrying out and concluding
investigations within their exclusive
economic zones
Russia also claims to want an impartial
investigation
as long as that investigation upholds
Russia's spurious accusations that the
United States was behind the attacks
we again categorically refute any
allegations that the United States Bears
any culpability for these attacks
as Russia continues its theatrical
hand-wringing and selective concern
regarding the protection of critical
infrastructure it is Raising entire
cities with Relentless attacks against
Ukraine
it is importing uavs from Iran and
flagrant violation of U.N security
Council 2231 and deploying them in
attacks that kill civilians in Ukraine
Russia's agenda here is simple
it is to overwhelm this council with
meetings on Nordstrom undermine ongoing
investigations and distract from its
ceaseless attacks against Ukraine's
power stations hospitals schools and
apartment buildings
ongoing National investigations must be
allowed the space to carry out their
work
this Council should reject repeated
meetings with no purpose other than to
waste time spread disinformation and
distract from the kremlin's Indus
indefensible war of aggression against
Ukraine thank you Mr President
thanks representative of the United
States for their statement and I give
the floor to the representative of Japan
thank you Mr President
thank briefers for their briefing
and I also thank informative input
inleta by Germany Sweden and Denmark
Mr President
energy resources including natural gas
are fundamental to people's lives
the global energy situation has been
tense in recent years
vandalism to critical infrastructure and
Facilities is an unacceptable act that
will help that will have a significant
impact on countless people
therefore Japan is deeply concerned
about the incident which happened to the
north string pipelines and long-term
damage and risk to the maritime
environment
Mr President
we are closely monitoring the and
looking forward to the progress of the
ongoing National investigations by the
authorities of Germany Sweden and
Denmark
we are confident that this investigation
will be conducted in a fair manner
we hope that the investigations by these
states will be completed as soon as
possible and that the result will be
provided to the security Council
it will be a task of the security
Council to address any matter that
concerns the peace and stability of the
International Community
but we don't want to go for speculation
without any subjective information
sorry any objective information
the security Council should however wait
for the national authorities to conclude
their works
I thank you Mr President
I thank the representative of Japan for
their statement
I shall now make a statement in my
capacity as a representative of the
United Kingdom
colleagues the UK condemns acts of
sabotage on critical National
infrastructure
we should treat the sabotage of the
Nordstrom Pipeline with utmost
seriousness
the International Community is concerned
about this act and wants clear answers
about what happened and who was
responsible
as we've said before the best way to get
those answers is to support the
impartial investigations of Denmark
Sweden and Germany
and to respect those processes
we do not believe it is good good use of
our time for the security Council to
start to prejudge the outcome of these
investigations dictate how they are
conducted or otherwise undermine them
we welcome the latest update sent by
Germany on behalf of Denmark and Sweden
and their commitment to updating the
security Council
their letter underlines the complexity
of the ongoing investigations and
underscores that this process will take
time
we are confident that when these
investigations conclude their findings
will be authoritative
we and fellow council members should
continue to offer our full support to
these investigations so that we can
establish who was responsible for these
acts
finally we must note Russia's
inconsistent attitude towards civilian
infrastructure
they claim outrage here
but are pursuing a systematic campaign
to Target civilian infrastructure in
their war of aggression against Ukraine
killing thousands of civilians in the
process
such hypocrisy should not surprise us
but it makes it hard to take anything
the Russians say on this subject at face
value
I resume my function as president for
the council
the representative of the Russian
Federation has asked for the floor to
make a further statement
I give them the floor
thank you Mr President
because we spoke at the very beginning
I'll allow myself first of all I wanted
to ask the representative of the U.S to
clarify something you said that affected
States
if I recall correctly the uh
you have the right and must participate
in this investigation
do you consider the Russian Federation
to be in affected State the state to
which that pipeline belonged to states
only the states on the coast to be part
of this group of effective States I'd
like to believe that effective states
does include the Russian Federation
otherwise it would simply be illogical
and therefore we trust and count on your
support so that our experts can join the
ongoing investigation and we have much
more justifications now and another
comments
I noticed that
statements which many of our Western
colleagues dedicated almost entirely to
the Ukrainian crisis allow us to clearly
trace the chain of causality uh
which guided those who committed these
crimes as well as those
foreign
initial stages at the very least thank
you
I thank the representative of the
Russian Federation for their statements
there are no more names inscribed on the
list of speakers
the meetings adjourned